hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll one of my favorite things to do
in Paris is to visit the catacombs
underneath the city itself these are an
extraordinary collection of tunnels that
are about 20 meters underground at the
height of a five-story building and
there are stories of course of people
sneaking in to sealed off areas to throw
massive parties and so forth but some of
the catacombs are explicitly open to the
public you walk down a rickety spiral
staircase and you find yourself
surrounded by bones this part of the
catacombs are used as a storage place
for the skeletal remains of literally
millions of Parisians from the 1700s
back then the art of the cemetery was
not quite as advanced as it is today and
bones were just piling up there are
stories of a heavy rainfall washing
bodily remains down the streets of Paris
itself so at some point they gathered up
literally millions of remains and put
them underground in these catacombs it's
a site that if you visit it will leave a
real impression an impression of your
mortality but also an impression of the
different ways in which different
cultures think about mortality to me as
an American going to the catacombs makes
me realise that it's not necessary to
have sort of the ponderous somber
attitude toward death that we have here
in the u.s. deep in the catacombs there
are little snippets of poetry on the
walls there are sometimes the skulls are
arranged in little heart shapes and so
forth it's a slightly more accepting
almost whimsical version of how we think
about death and we know that different
cultures think about death very
differently in Mexico
there's the Day of the Dead dia de
Muertos which celebrates and honors the
ends of our lives in the United States
we don't do this we don't celebrate we
don't honor death we're certainly not
whimsical about it we treat it with
utmost seriousness and if anything we
try to ignore the impending death that
we're all going to face as much as we
can this attitude can have a deleterious
impact on one of the most singular
moments of the
human life the moment that it ends when
we want to think about death we should
be asking ourselves where is it that we
want to die how do we want it to happen
if we can possibly have any control over
that how can we plan for it so recently
a movement has emerged known as death
positivity it's a movement that works to
create a more healthy realistic attitude
toward the inevitability of death and to
celebrate death as a capstone to a life
well-lived to have the cultural and
artistic aspects of death taken a little
bit more seriously
so today's guest is Megan Rosenblum a
medical librarian who is a leader in
this death positive movement Megan is an
Associate Director for instruction
services at the USC Norris Medical
Library and she's also the author of
forthcoming book dark archives you'll
hear what that book is actually about
later in the podcast
she's also the co-founder and director
of the death salon the official event of
the order of the good death an
organization devoted to exploring ways
to prepare a deaf phobic culture for our
inevitable mortality it's going to
happen to all of us eventually so let's
go
[Music]
okay making rosenbloom welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks so you're a
librarian but a medical librarian how
does what kind of weird career
trajectory ends up with one being a
medical librarian in particular well
some people just set out to be a medical
librarian you can take medical library
classes in library school so you know
baseline in order to be an actual
librarian and not just work at a library
you need a master's in library science a
lot of people just think that you sit
and read books all day or checkout books
all day I wish but it is one of those
rare degrees like one of those rare
positions that you actually need a
masters not a PhD is specifically
ambassadors so some people when they're
getting their masters they take specific
courses or tracks in medical
librarianship I didn't do that I kind of
ended up in a medical library in a sort
of backward fashion some people you know
are physicians and then decide they want
to be librarians and then they go to
library school and then use their
medical expertise I my first job in
libraries which is still at the same
place I am but this is my third position
there now I was you know head of
metadata and content so it was more
about the publishing stuff and all the
like describing the resources and making
them work and making people be able to
get them so it wasn't super it didn't
matter if I had much medical background
although while I was getting my degree I
was working in medical publishing so I
did have some very baseline you know
understanding of Medicine but it's not
like I'm a medical professional but I am
now a medical information professional I
know all about the information but I
wouldn't want me to perform any surgery
on you or anything like that
and did your special interest in the
subject of death come before you became
a medical librarian or did that grow out
of that
yeah I think I always had gothis
tendencies you know but didn't really
kind of recognize it but then in terms
of professional interest and you know
learning about different cultures and
history and and that kind of thing
and getting involved in this whole death
positive community I actually came to it
from history medicine and it came to
history medicine from rare books so my
first love in libraries was rare books
and while I was in Philadelphia I was
you know working a publishing company
but while I was getting my a degree I
was I volunteered a couple places and
one of them was the AIDS library which I
was doing I was cataloging some other
archive material around like the very
early days of the AIDS epidemic which
was completely heart wrenching but kind
of showed me the importance of that kind
of material you know and then I was a
docent at the Rosenbach Museum in
Philadelphia a lot of people don't know
about that place but it is a basically a
rare-book museum the dr. Rosen back was
the rare bookseller to the Stars he
built all the main variable collections
in the country so the huntingdon he was
his one of his main sellers Henry
hunting Huntington's the maiden seller
was dr. Rosen back you know that kind of
guy and so he has some of the craziest
rare books in this you know house in
Philadelphia and I would give tours of
that so he has just off the time I had
the actual manuscript for James Joyce's
Ulysses like the handwritten one it's
not in Iran it's in Philadelphia
he's got all the notes and everything
for Bram Stoker's Dracula he's got the
only known extant copy of Poor Richard's
Almanack the first one the 1733 just it
just a taste I mean it's pretty
incredible
growing up on the East Coast in
Philadelphia in particular where I knew
I grew up there's all these crazy
historical things that you know here in
LA it's a little bit harder to find but
there's all these collections handed
down through the centuries there are a
lot in LA too but yeah it's a little
harder to find in Philadelphia the
history is sort of just right in your
face
before I was a librarian I was a
journalist so I just felt like I knew
everything about the city I know all the
nooks and crannies and fun things there
was to be had because it was kind of a
small place anyway but the history yeah
and so the history and the rare books
were the thing that really got me
interested and then I I wanted to come
to LA and so I just kind of you know
found what turned out to be a really
lucky break of a job in a medical
library and when I got there you know
they during the interview they're like
okay this hard part of the interview
where we ask you all the hard questions
and it was in the rare book room and I'm
like no problem so ah no one at the
library really cared about rare books
and had for a long time so there's this
collection but nobody was really doing
anything with it so I kind of took it
upon myself to start learning about them
and teaching with them and that kind of
thing and during the course of that was
when I sort of got interested in the way
that the corpse and the cadavers were
used in the history of medicine and most
specifically the way they were sourced
like who did these bodies come from
right because usually it's not a way
that we would find very you know
consensual or ethically okay today yeah
and so that was kind of the firt my
first interest in dead bodies I guess I
came at it from this completely other
way but I was doing some public lectures
about things you know sourcing bodies
for anatomical learning and that was
when Caitlin Doty like saw me do a talk
and was kind of like hey she looks
useful I think it was kind of a it
wasn't so much she knows everything
about death but hmm organized librarian
hmm yeah and Kayla Doty is the founder
or in some sense of this death positive
movement yeah yeah I mean yeah she she
coined the phrase death positive she is
the you know Alpha and Omega and so she
started she had started this group
before called the order of the good
death which was like this online
collective of academics and artists and
writers and morticians
various death professionals that were
doing interesting things like new
groundbreaking things talking about
history in a new way kind of changing
the landscape of what was deemed
acceptable to do or not do in terms of
you know let's bring back the home
funeral let's bring back the green
burial let's do that kind of thing so
she was kind of built this collective
and then she added some new people to
the collective after I met her including
me and I felt like oh I'm so unqualified
for this there was you know this list of
people just doing incredible work and we
were on on this sort of email thread and
we're like oh wouldn't be cool if we
could just get together for like a party
or something
it was literally that you know but it
gave you a purpose it was like oh and if
we got together for a party and you know
that would be impossible some of the
people were in Australia and stuff like
that but then some people were like well
you know if it was a kind of like a
conference I might be able to you know
get permission to go if I was doing a
talk at a thing or whatever and that was
like well you know I just planned my
wedding in Los Angeles so I actually
know some things about venues and that
kind of thing and then I just kind of
ended up organizing you know with the
help of other people what stuff we
organized this first death salon we
called it so so on like the you know
18th century makes us think we're in
France yes yeah let's get a bunch of
thinkers together and see what happens
kind of feel and it was only it was kind
of invite only there were only like 30
people and then we did one public event
at a bar venue like a place where you
would see music and we got there and
there was like 300 people there were
like okay and then the Atlantic did a
big feature on us and then it just kind
of blew open and the next thing we know
we're in London and we're in I mean it
just really snowballed very quickly and
so decimal and this sort of the physical
event now annual we did a couple a year
at one point and they got to be too much
so it was like once a year now we go to
some city and we take over for a weekend
and we have dozens of lectures and
different kinds of artistic performances
and workshops and parties and so yeah I
mean the one that's coming up in the
fall is at it's in Mount Auburn cemetery
in Boston so it's not I've walked by
there many times right so we are
actually in a cemetery this time and
they have these great chapels and we're
giving talks in the chapel but we're
having basically you know on Thursday we
have one a small group that's just all
day hands on home funeral workshop so
that's Thursday and then Friday it's
kind of an open field day where we're
gonna have people doing talks all over
the cemetery and dance performances and
all sorts of things that you can just
stumble into things including like
guided tours of the history of Mount
Auburn because it has incredibly
important that history again yeah it's
probably one it's probably the most
important historical cemetery in the
country it's kind of started that idea
of the field cemetery the place you
would walk around and have picnics and
things that was the first iteration of
that and then Friday night in one of the
chapels were having this very this
Edward Gorey themed Oh perfect
fundraiser cuz he's from the Cape and
and we have the ever gory houses like
coming with artifacts and you know so
that'll be really fun and then Saturday
and Sunday it's just talk all day this
sounds great and but but let me back up
a little bit because just the phrase
death positivity mmm-hmm we want to get
straight what exactly this is supposed
to mean I mean you're not in favor of
dying right it's not like we are saying
that dying is good let's all die right
but it's more like correct me if I'm
wrong we're gonna die
let's accept it let's you know not feel
squeamish about it let's talk about it
and let's trying to make it as
meaningful and pleasant as possible is
that about right right so you know we
take the phrase death positive it kind
of for some people it's it's sort of ooh
that sounds horrible and it is
provocative on purpose but the kind of
background of it is more like sex
or body-positive right so it's hey
here's this thing that we feel really
uncomfortable talking about let's open
up conversations let's explore the ways
that this is dealt with in different
cultures and time periods and different
communities and what are some of the
issues in this like just about as
intersectional as you can possibly
imagine every sort of slice and dice of
possibility
like let's explore that let's see you
know cross you know like cross time
cross culture let's like talk about
these things and what can we learn from
that so it's sort of when you open up
conversation then it D stigmatizes it a
little bit and then you can start to
it's an easy way intellectually if you
start intellectually then it's an easier
way to get into the personal and the you
know that kind of dealing with a topic
that you don't really want to deal with
we live in this society that's really in
death denial we just pretend it's never
gonna happen to us and then when it does
and when it comes into our lives because
a family member or something with us
then it's an emergency we don't know how
to deal with it and then you just kind
of do what you think is the only option
the you know the $10,000 you know
funeral with the embalmed body and the
casket with the viewing in the concrete
vault in the ground like who turns out
not only are those things not the only
option they're actually very specific to
our time in place and they're not even
the way we did things like a hundred
years ago yet for some reason we have
this myopia where it's just this one
thing actually you have a lot of options
yeah you know because some people think
that it's illegal not to embalm a body
some funeral professionals tell people
that you know and so this is like hey
let's educate ourselves at a time that's
not at the time of need let's engage
with things on a level that's intriguing
you know I mean how can you not be
intrigued about this great mystery that
we all end up dealing with you know how
is that not interesting and it's like an
easy gateway into more difficult
conversations or
and is it fair to say that it is our
specific time in place the United States
and the beginning of 21st century here
that is more in denial than average I
did find this wonderful quote from one
of your colleagues Joanna Edmond Stein
mm-hmm
only in the United States she said were
images of death absent from art and
daily life you know there's plenty of
stories if you're a tourist in Europe
you go in Paris or in Italy to the
catacombs and there's all these skulls
and bones all over the place and Mexico
of course celebrates the Day of the Dead
very famously are we weird that way is
it is it is it worse here than anywhere
else yeah it's tough you know there may
be some other places where it's just as
bad but it is really noticeably bad here
yeah and it kind of is sort of
historical trajectory with that as the
civil war really kind of took us the
civil war in its aftermath was the thing
that separated us from from European
heritage in terms of the way that we
deal with death right before that we're
more or less doing the same thing it
wasn't that different but then with the
civil war it was the first time that
people were dying far away from home so
normally before the Civil War you
usually got you were born at home you
got sick at home you were taking care of
at home you died at home were laid out
at home buried on the homestead buried
at the local church art you know your
family would take care of your body you
know there was no funeral professionals
there was no Undertaker's or anything
like that's also what it was like in
Europe at the time yeah that was pretty
much just the way that that it went
usually you you probably didn't have as
much land in Europe so it's pretty much
the churchyard but more or less the same
and then for the first time you got a
lot of people dying all at once still
the amount of people the amount of
soldiers that died in some war is more
than any other American war all put
together and that's just the soldiers
not even all the civilians it's like the
entire city of Philadelphia hey like
right now if everybody Philly died that
is kind of comparable like that
level of you know death in just a few
years and so and for the first time
normally if you had if you're fighting a
warrior fighting in your you know local
area there's a battle down the streams
the militia that would be gathered and
right exactly this time people are going
really far away and dying and then
there's no you know their bodies were
just left on battlefields and things
like that so if you had some means there
were a couple of new technologies that
made it so that you could bring people
home and one is the train but in order
to get on the train you needed to do
something to stabilize the body so it
didn't like you can't just have rotting
corpse on a train
so these battlefield surgeons started
doing embalming and that was really the
thing like okay we can stabilize his
body enough to get it home for a proper
burial
then they took Lincoln's body on a train
tour around the u.s. and just it bombed
them and it bombed him and fun and so
people are seeing this lifelike course
of the President and isn't that
impressive kind of thing and then over
time not right away but over time then
embalming became like the normal thing
to do I bomb never really caught on in
other countries people don't routinely
do it so it's such a part of our so even
now even now Europe what about like
Latin America not really know Mexico
don't really do it you know it's just
like you know some people do but it's
not like the default was it originally a
prestige thing we're the richest
families embalming because they could
afford it I mean I think in order to you
would have to have some money in order
to be able to get someone to go find
your son and then perform the service
and then get them on a train all those
things would probably cost a lot of
money right and then yeah I mean we used
to have a room in our house called the
parlor nobody calls it that anymore it's
really old-fashioned but then we took
these professionals who were doing
funeral service like oh well you can't
embalm because it's full of nasty
chemicals you need a professional to do
this you can't let the women do it at
home
need you know a professional that you
pay and so instead of having a body and
a parlor in your house you take it to
the funeral parlor and then the parlour
becomes a living room because it's for
the living and not for your dead bodies
you know so over tying these little bits
and pieces just kind of add up to this
completely different way of doing it and
then you you know we're here in Los
Angeles and it's a perfect example of
the sort of forest lawn is kind of the
epitome of the death denial cemetery
because the the tombstones don't stand
up because it's gonna look like a
cemetery they all have to be flat you
know so you can almost ignore this bunch
of dead bodies cuz there's just a big
rolling hills and where they bury the
children it's called Slumberland it's
really kind of disturbing with the
euphemisms and all the things that they
do to try to sanitize away and you know
graves in cemeteries and the United
States of modern graves they have these
huge concrete vaults in the ground so
it's not just a casket in the ground
it's a casket inside the set and inside
a concrete vault in the ground so you
know ecologically it's pretty wasteful
that they do that partially so that it's
easy to mow the grass so there's no
settling it's like yeah so these are all
things where if you told somebody even
in a European country like oh yeah we
have these huge plots of land that would
be worth zillions of dollars in the
other country and you're just four dead
people for always you get your gray
forever which is not a common thing
right in Europe and in South America I
know that you get your grade for a
little while and at some point you're
cleaned out and someone else gets that
place right because land is a premium
and it didn't used to be so much here we
had we were very land rich it's not
really the case anymore but it was like
for a long time so you know you get this
real estate forever we put a bunch of
expensive and
you know concrete metals and heavy
metals and things in the ground with
your body and we try to preserve your
dead body as long as possible so that it
looks like you're alive is so weird it's
like what are you doing so when people
say things about other cultures and you
know Caitlin's Caitlyn Dodi's latest
book From Here to Eternity you know she
goes around to a lot of different places
and talks about you know their death
practices and from a really you know
respectful like it could like that that
idea I could sound horrible like wait
lady goes around and but but the way she
does it is really well informed it's
really sensitive but you know when she's
talking about this place in in Indonesia
where the village digs up their
relatives every year changes their
clothes takes them around and you know
shows their their corpses like okay
here's the new baby here's the new well
here's the new whatever people write all
that's disgusting it's so disrespectful
it's like no it's way it's not embalmed
corpse this is a decomposing corpse if
it's been in the ground for a while yeah
it's like a mummy because it's dry okay
you know they kind of look mummified but
is definitely there's no mistaking the
dead body is very dead and you know that
act is done with utmost love and respect
you know meanwhile if you told someone
in that village what we do they would be
horrified you know so it's it's like
it's so about where you're from in your
time in place and but once you start
learning about other ways of doing
things you realize just how weird we
really are and that hey you know maybe
if I'm not comfortable with the whole
embalming thing maybe I don't have to do
it you know what what tell me more about
what it was like before we invented this
new way of doing it so you would have
not only had a funeral at home in some
sense but you would have died at home
probably right the idea of dying in
hospitals it's also a relatively modern
invention it is yeah
clinical medicine sort of became a thing
in
the French Revolution before that their
hospitals were like charity hospitals so
you don't have a family so the church
will run this place for you to go die in
basically and then when during the
French Revolution they were kind of like
okay we have a lot of quack doctors who
are saying a lot of crazy things but
what if we use this group of poor people
to train doctors on real people instead
of just being like an apprentice on
someone you can kind of learn but with a
lot of people not just like one or two
people and that you have to pass tests
and things in order to be a doctor and
that was sort of the framework and so
that that idea is called the Paris
school that's like when medicine was
like really getting codified as I coach
profession yeah it's like
professionalized thing but still for
most people that wasn't even relevant
because you can if you were rich you
could have a doctor come to your house
to help you out
but you would still die at home for sure
you wouldn't it would be scandalous to
die in a hospital if you had money that
would be just unbelievable and so it was
really the hospital stayed for the poor
for quite a long time into the 19th
century for sure and yeah so yeah you
would be taken care of at home die at
home often buried at home the funeral
would be at home you didn't have they
just would wash the body you might have
some flowers out you know that kind of
thing the family would wash the body yes
not some stranger yeah but so now this
whole idea of you dying in the hospital
after prolonged illness your body goes
directly from hospital to funeral home
and potentially from hospital or funeral
home to Crematory and you come back in a
box of ashes without any of your family
necessarily being with you during all
that process it can be very
destabilizing for people you know that
one minute you know someone's right here
and the next min
they're in a box on my shelf that's like
really hard for people to process so a
lot of the appeal of something like a
home funeral is I'm taking care of this
family member and while I'm doing it I'm
understanding the transition between
them being alive and then being a corpse
so it was part of the death positive
movement to encourage home funerals or
is there a set of different possible
ways to go and you just want people to
be more cognizant of their choices I
think yeah it's more did you know you
have this option and you can be as
involved or not involved as you want
this is not it's not illegal to keep a
body in your house you know people have
this idea of where the second somebody
dies oh my god we have to call 9-1-1
this is emergency they have to leave
immediately and you can't do something
like maybe I want to brush mom's hair
and make her look nice or whatever it's
it's this sort of reaction because we're
so not used to being around dead bodies
where we used to be around them all the
time that it's like oh my god what do I
do it's an emergency but then if you
actually knew you could do things like
that or if you knew you could do a
witness cremation you can go to the
Crematory and you can push the button
then you can be there with your family
member like for the last time you know
that was that was something that was
mentioned in Caitlyn's first book and
she got so many responses like I had no
idea that I could have done that I wish
I could have done that now I know you
know like there's so little information
people don't share those things people
and people in the industry think oh
people don't want those you know yeah
devasena is a big Chinese thing the
Chinese do it nobody else does it or
whatever and then you know for people to
be like wait I could have done you know
that is it so the death positive
movement there are certain things that
come up a lot like you know home
funerals and green burial and stuff like
that but those things aren't for
everybody you know and so we don't pass
judgment on people if they want the
whole big embalmed everything it's more
you know hey there are other options and
we support your ability to choose and
presumably there's an issue also because
a lot of people who will die
our infirm they're already sick right
and maybe they're elderly and our
culture makes a choice to sort of do
everything we can to eat every last
minute of life out of people is there a
relationship between the death positive
movement and end-of-life care and
end-of-life choices and death with
dignity and so forth oh absolutely yeah
I mean we were helpful with getting
Death with Dignity legalized in
California
why do you explain exactly what that
entails so it's um it's been Death with
Dignity you know you've it's been called
a lot of things over the years and a lot
of people don't like using words like
euthanasia that gives you this really
bad you know association with Nazis and
that is no one wants to do it with that
and then I forget what the other one
that people were using a little
different but there are certain phrases
like that go in and out of the vogue
you're the one right now the cultural
baggage around the whole idea yeah so
right now what people generally call
this Death with Dignity and oh it's just
it's suicide that's the other that's
that was a 90s thing people don't call
it that anymore because suicide has this
big stigma people big association with
it and if you're a hundred and one and
you have been suffering with liver
failure for like many months are you
really committing suicide I mean is that
really what you're doing well even the
word commit we don't use commit anymore
because that's a crime you commit a
crime right so that kind of the words
you use are really important and they
change over time but anyway that's my
little hobby horse about that but the
death of dignity is when you pass when
you get a terminal diagnosis and they
say you have something like six months
to live there's a specific thing then
you can choose to see your doctor and
you have to go through many different
hurdles in order to get this so it's not
like oh I just want to do this okay fine
you know it's not like that
the doctor can't administer you know the
medicine because that against you know
that do no harm kind of thing I'd be
proud to go that's right
and so it's like though they can't do
that
you can self administer you have to do
with yourself right and you have to meet
certain cognitive criteria for you to be
able to do that so if you have you know
Alzheimer's or dementia you don't have
the option of doing that which you know
is sad but understandable like why you
wouldn't you know like if you're not
sound like yeah in some way that you
feel the important thing is they have to
be a hundred percent sure that you are
not under duress in any way that you're
not you know someone in your life isn't
trying to force you into it that it's
your choice and you are informed and
then after many you know visits and all
this bureaucratic hurdles of absolutely
it is not it is a long process yeah then
you are given the drugs to then use or
not right for some people just having it
is so relieving like if it gets too bad
I have it option all right a little bit
of volition a little bit of
self-determination is there yeah it's
like okay if this gets as bad as it
possibly could I have the ability to do
something about it and that is you know
comforting to people in the end of their
lives yeah some people make use of it
and some people don't and if you know
it's coming if you know you have a
terminal diagnosis and you feel like at
some point of your choosing that this is
your that this is a good time for you to
do that you know you call your family
over you have a big party you do
whatever you want to do and then you
have this option then that is that's
what it is that's death with dignity
because dignity part is I'm gonna choose
the way I I do this you know and then
I'm gonna do it in a safe comfortable
like fashion and this is the law in
California now and how many places yeah
so I'm trying to I'm not sure exactly
how many states it's legal in right now
but Oregon was one of the first I
believe it's in Washington it's in
California although there was a recent
chow
to it but I think it was overturned and
I think things are okay right now it's
very recent kind of challenge to that
there's a handful say it's not everybody
we have any idea of how often people are
taking the option and actually doing it
I don't know if I'm not sure what kind
of statistics people are keeping on that
but Death with Dignity is a thing that
falls within death positivity because
it's about choice right right it's like
this is you have an option you have
choice you have some agency in the end
of your life we have a lot of people
involved in our lot in our community who
are hospice workers we have death doulas
a lot of death doulas that's like a
really popular thing right explain what
that is so pretty much if there's
someone on the birth if there's a job on
the birth side there is a comparable job
on the other side makes that so death
doulas have varying levels just like
birth doulas of you know training in
right you know responsibility well yeah
certification of various Kylie it's it's
less certified than the birth side
because it's less of them you know a lot
of people perform this service but don't
call it that
you know hospice workers can kind of be
a death toll if that's how you choose to
call yourself that but it's basically
easing the transition right what you can
do to make people comfortable and you
know that kind of thing so whatever you
do that isn't helping in the transition
from life to death same as from you know
in the birthing process whatever you
need to do to help that person that all
falls within the doula like Lange frame
there must be enormous political and
social forces arrayed against the desire
to give people these choices right we
all remember the death panels
controversy just the very idea that you
would plan to die rather than going
kicking and screaming and eking out
every last minute can be used as a
weapon right is that do you think that
the tide is turning you think that we're
seeing movement in the death positive
direction here
the level to which death positivity has
connected with people in a very short
timeframe is pretty astonishing I mean
the fact that we have multiple
best-selling authors and events people
call their events death positive people
align themselves with that even if we
don't know them you know I think the
first time I started seeing people
calling things death positive and I
didn't know who they were that was a big
you know deal but I mean the amount the
sheer amount of people who are like yes
this is me you know is it's pretty
astonishing our community is huge and
growing all the time and so on that hand
this is a this is a need that a lot of
people feel like it's been absent it's
not been an option or they've been
working in a really really small area
but they didn't think about all the
other people who can kind of who are
sort of similarly aligned like you know
a lot of the people who are speaking at
decimal on this time they've been
working on home funerals for decades you
know but that was such a teeny little
rish of a thing and most and they would
be working in their community in this
like way now we're global and we have
you know hundreds of thousands of people
who watch videos and buy books and come
to events and talk on line with each
other and do this whole thing so it's
kind of and you know maybe you were
interested in it because you thought
Caitlin's videos were funny but then
you're like actually I want to start
helping people do home funerals like
that kind of thing can happen
nevertheless we are in a very difficult
political climate for that kind of thing
because it death positivity is
empowering for regular people it often
results in very inexpensive options and
that you don't need a professional for
it is we are very openly intersectional
and inclusive and we work all the time
be more and more intersectional and
inclusive and that rubbed some people
the wrong way sometimes but that is and
you know we are you know ultimately a
social justice movement and if you don't
like that then you might not like us
anymore
even if you liked our videos and stuff
before and there has to be a
complicating factor of religion right or
even just of what people think is going
to happen after death even if it's not
in the context of an organized religion
but certainly in principle I would
imagine that how one approaches the
final moments of your life or the life
of a loved one will be affected by
whether or not do you think that's the
end
do you not think they're going to a
better place or a worse place or
someplace in between yeah definitely I
mean religion is a is a factor but I
wouldn't say it's necessarily a thing
that would draw people away from the
movement because a lot of very
traditions like Judaism and Islam
you know those what they still do is
greet varial they don't in bomb they
wrap a body wash a body ritualistic
washing of a body wrapping it in a sheet
and quick burial you know that kind of
thing is you know now what wait people
outside of those traditions are fighting
to get included into what quote unquote
traditional cemeteries is the stuff
they've been doing a lot right so that
it depends on the religion and and also
those things change over time I mean you
know it until I think it was until
Vatican 2 or something like that
nobody would ever consider getting
cremated if you're a Catholic I mean who
you know and now so yeah that's ok so
even in Europe where well in Europe the
rates are even higher of cremation most
European countries you're looking at
like 96 percent of people get cremated
we just passed the 50% mark but in the
80s it was something like 12% Wow in the
u.s. so we were way way behind the times
Japan is like 99.9% their children
should not go into the embalming
business in school I yeah I mean I
personally would if my kid wanted to be
an embalmer I would be upset because I
don't want her to get cancer oh it is a
very it's a very dangerous profession in
that way occupationally dangerous let
alone on the other stuff right so so
yeah I'm not super into embalming as a
idea but you know current plans are me
donating my body to medical school which
means I will be in balm tattoos the enth
if I you know if if that's what happens
to me so it's like you have to make some
decisions they have you had anyone close
to you died since you became involved in
the movement yeah mm-hmm it was a pretty
tragic death too so this was my niece
and she was 24 Wow and she died of an
opioid overdose and she left behind a
six year old severely autistic child and
an infant so talk about what is the
worst death you can think of about that
kind right we're the order the good
death this is the opposite of that all
and all the things that were surrounding
it that I had to like go home and go
into that it was like so it's just
everybody's worst nightmare you know I
mean just the worst and so if that
happened like five years before that I
literally don't know what I would have
done in terms of I honestly would
probably have just like dissociated from
the whole thing if I were out here if
you know 3,000 miles away be like oh I'm
sorry I can't come home or something I
would just completely be like good luck
with that
if I just couldn't deal with it I mean a
lot of people can't deal with situations
and then they're like I need to preserve
myself I'm going to write peace out of
this but I knew that my mom like she
needed me
you know she needed me my brother name
people needed me and so I kind of swung
into action and that is a thing that
when I am faced with something that I'm
you know I can't deal with or you know I
think is like something really difficult
if I can find a way to do some good in
the situation then it makes me feel it
gives me a sense of control over things
I had no control over right
so me being able to help with I helped
with the arrangements with my brother
you know I came in and I was talking to
my mom about this side and the other
thing and then I continually talked to
her about about my niece you know cuz
she she got a tattoo with her name on it
and you know that like my mom was
extremely affected by it and still is
and so other people you know it's been
like a couple years now just like maybe
to two or three other people just kind
of push push it out of their minds but
my mom is still in very deep grief and
then I let her be in it and I try to
support her in that and we have authors
like Megan Devine I would recommend her
book to anybody ever which is called
it's okay for not if you're not okay
it's okay that you're not okay and it's
like hey grief like it's not it doesn't
have a time limit it's like oh that was
six months ago you're still upset about
that yeah right you know well you know
you really need to get over it or you
know you could have another baby you
know that kind of those things that
people say are so horrible but they come
from this idea of what I'm gonna fix
things and so although I just know I
just said that I was coming in to like
do things to help I knew I couldn't fix
it but we also and we're but we're bad
at it because it's part of the fact that
our culture denies that death even
happens right so we were not trained
we're not anticipating where we don't
have good guidelines for proper behavior
you know with the best of intentions
people can say the most heartbreaking me
inappropriate things at a time of death
because we won't face up to it right if
you don't have much experience dealing
with death and all you know is kind of
like things that other people say then
you end up saying these cliches that can
be really really hurtful to people
because they're the one on the receiving
end of you saying oh well she's in a
better place it's like well well so does
that make me a bad person because I want
her here and not in some better place or
what if I'm not religious then I don't
like that idea
you know or you should be happy to have
the time you had it's like I can I can't
have both you know like you pretty much
have an answer to every of the all of
those cliches which means like you're
not really thinking about what you're
saying cuz if you did then you would
realize that what you're saying is super
hurtful even though you're trying to
help you know so like familiarizing
yourself and get to learn about these
things and really just kind of trying to
be there it's like I found it personally
very helpful so I was it wasn't easy I
won't pretend that it was I won't
pretend I had a dandy old time at my
niece's funeral or anything like that
but the fact that I was able to go in
and help out with some things then went
like when I look back I'm like okay well
I feel like I was able to help and that
makes me feel better and one of the
simple things is just letting grief
happen in some way right there's no
clever saying or condolence that you can
give that makes the grief go away like
like you said it will be there and it
will go away and come back and people
deal with it in their own ways
yeah it's like hey yeah this really
sucks or I don't know what to say but
I'm here here for you yeah you know but
it seems like a lot of the death
positive movement is not just about
dealing with the specific deaths but
also the idea of death right and
creating something more cultural and
artistic and meaningful about the
acceptance that this is going to come to
all of us alright so part of the death
denial idea and so that phrase is really
it was popularized by this philosopher
named Ernest Becker
and he had those best-selling book in
1975 or something called the denial of
death and his construct which is
something that is one of the founding
tenets of our our movement is that the
fact so where are these animals that we
know know that we're gonna die right we
don't know about other animals level of
understanding you know there's probably
but it's we know for sure that we are at
you know we know you know very we're
special in this certain way that we
definitely like humans know that they're
gonna die someday and the terror of that
is too much to handle so we try to do
these psychological things to like
distance and like change that and ignore
that idea we have this death anxiety
we're trying to do something with it
so basically all of culture comes from
the death anxiety thing so if you are
okay I know I'm gonna die someday I
really don't like that idea I wouldn't
leave something of myself behind I'm
going to make another human being I'm
going to make some art or record a
podcast or you know they you know strive
to the heights of my profession and I
hope someone will remember me and put my
name on a building or whatever you know
all those impulses the pyramids and you
know writing books or you know having
having people have good memories about
you to be put in most benign terms right
there made some more feelings behind
yeah the idea that you would care about
a legacy after you're dead is a really
weird thing but everybody does care at
least to some extent people don't be
like you know oh I don't care if anyone
talks about me or what people I don't
care what music you play at my funeral I
don't care what you do with my dead body
throw it in a hole I don't care you know
those kind of things are pretty unusual
and usually if someone's like I really
don't care at all I'm I don't care if
I'm if I'm gonna die tomorrow I don't
care whatever happens to be who cares
this peep
tend to like protest too much I think
the general human condition is okay one
of this push-and-pull you know and the
more you face your mortality and engage
with these ideas in a way usually
starting that is comfortable with you
like for me it's knowledge acquisition
and you know librarian yeah yeah I mean
that's the way I get comfortable by
learning things and trying to process
them by learning you know and you know
you you interact with it in your way
and then the repeated exposure then
makes each exposure a little less severe
and then you're able to yeah when you
make plans so you make choices and you
talk about it with your loved ones and
you have this ongoing relationship with
death you actually end up being a less
anxious and more happy person in general
that's usually the the reaction and
other cultures have something like this
more built in than we do these days I
mean it you know if you look at it one
way I have a friend who is who works on
a Buddhist meditation retreat and she's
like yeah this is basically you know to
her she's like yeah yeah we do we do
corpse meditation we sit and think about
what it's like to be a corpse we do that
all the time you know so there's there
are certain yeah there are certain
disciplines and or religions or whatever
where that's just baked in but in our
current you know state in America in
2018 you know are increasingly also a
secular state the some of the things
that get lost are things like the
importance of ritual of marking passages
from one stage to the next and you know
why do we care why is there a wedding
industrial complex you know why do we
care about that kind of thing because it
matters to mark the change from being a
single person to being a married person
that matters like who care who gives a
crap about having a birthday party like
who cares about being going from age 1
to 2 I care I care a lot I'm a big
believer in rituals like all of my PhD
students when
defend their thesis they get a bottle of
champagne and I get a bottle and put up
on the wall and some of the other
professors are like why bothering with
this you know they're gonna go on and do
their thing but it's a like you say it's
a rite of passage it's marking an
accomplishment something important in
your life yeah it matters it feels it's
important and and you know what I talked
about before was going from the hospital
and then right into you know then there
just disappear you don't get that
demarcation of the change of that person
being here and then not here and it
makes a lot harder for you to process
that like well we have funerals so
should funerals be more fun I mean it
depends on the person and you know what
they wanted I but also what the family
like what is the vibe of your family you
know are you an Irish wake kind of
family you know mine kind of would sort
of be English weeks for those who don't
know being famous for having lots of
drinking and revelry as well as you know
honoring the dead well because you're
telling singing so you know yeah that
kind of thing I could see that you know
I see the appeal for sure but yeah like
what's meaningful to you what feels like
what works a transition you know the
funeral is for the living but we have
lots of ways to set things up so that
your funeral but also most importantly
the end of your life is a thing that
you've you know aligns with with your
preferences that's the best yeah we
don't really have we really have much of
that in most of human history did you
get that kind of control yeah and our
laws are sort of is something I've been
reading about a lot lately because I've
been reading a lot about the legal like
stuff for my book and American loss
especially are like unusually permissive
about the like wishes of the deceased
that's something that in other even in
European countries they're like what who
cares about what you think they wanted
or what they said they wanted
but here it's like very important when
you say you want you know and another
aspect is the leaving behind of relics
or parts of ourselves which has I'm sure
you know is worth the whole conversation
all by itself but one aspect you
mentioned your books I definitely want
to get a plug in for the book it doesn't
exist yet it's not published yet but
tell us about the book you're writing I
won't we deal what it's about you can
say that okay
so I'll give you the nice big 50-cent
phrase because that's always a you know
a big question mark over people's heads
it's a book is about Anthropy dharmic
bibliothek ii of course it is yeah I
mean whose isn't sells itself
oh yeah no I need you to read another
book about Africa terrific bibliography
which is so let's break it out anthro
human dermis skin biblio books Peggy's a
little harder it's like fasten fasten
okay guys so books founded human skin
that's a now we got to ask you're not
actually gonna have a special edition
bound in human skin are you gonna go for
that right nope no current plans it's
funny though a lot of people ask me oh
that's one of the first questions going
isn't that illegal and the question and
the answer is it's complicated I
wouldn't test it but there isn't a
specific Allah says you cannot bound
behind a [ __ ] human skin eyes illegal
right but there are a lot of things
there are a lot of laws and our laws in
the US are all pretty much based in
States so different states have
different laws about whether you can
sell human remains like can I buy a
human skull I can in some states in
other states I can't if there were a law
against binding books in human skin you
would have to wonder what provoked the
legislature to actually do that there's
a story there
for sure and so there isn't really um
any codified rules that say no you can't
do this but just because it doesn't say
you can't doesn't mean you would want to
be the one to test what the definition
of desecration of a corpse means but it
has been done historically yeah so
ending books in human skin most people
usually associate
that idea because it sounds so ghoulish
and horrible the first thing people
think is oh that must've been a Nazi
thing but actually it wasn't you know we
don't have currently any even alleged
books from that actual error they're all
over a hundred years old
um and but it's usually had a doctor
involved so we've got history medicine
and rare books and death altogether
you're the person to write this book
yeah and the person turns out I didn't
set out in life to be the human skin
book lady but it's kind of what happened
and so it's weird because the rumors of
the books of these books started at the
same time that clinical medicine started
when I talked about the French
Revolution so there are alleged books
from that era but most of them were
either you know executed prisoners
executed murderers they would then it
would be an extra punishment to then
while they're detecting which was a
punishment getting dissected as a
punishment and only murderers got
dissected for a while they would you
know the doctors would sometimes take a
piece of skin and then bind a book of
their trial or something as like hey
look at this this is an extra punishment
but then the other ones were really just
doctors who were book collectors and had
access to these materials that no one
else had access to and it was like the
what Michele Foucault called the
clinical gaze of the way that a doctor
looks at patient they have to have a
certain amount of objectification of
like distancing clinical distancing to
be able to do your job because if you
thought about okay I'm going into room B
and I'm gonna cut open this person's
liver then I'm gonna cut it you know
that kind of thing like if you actually
thought about what you were doing in the
way like looking at this person and
thinking about all their family and
their all these things you couldn't
function it's too much to bear so you
kind of mentally distance yourself but
if you take that to a very far extreme
then it's more like oh well they were
gonna throw out the skin we were gonna
throw it out anyway I might as well save
it for a book later you know and that's
what happened and it happened like
surprisingly a lot
so the book is it was claimed to happen
right I mean so right now we're left
with actual books copies of volumes and
libraries or collections that there's
some documentary claim that this is
bound in human skin and part of your job
is to figure out whether that's true
well so for the longest time this was
just a ghoulish story right oh did you
hear about the this book that exists and
it says it's in human skin and a lot of
people like thought they were you know
maybe fake or whatever but then there is
a chemist at Harvard who one of the
conservators at Harvard asked oh you're
doing these like proteomics like tests
these peptide mask fingerprinting which
is a very common easy you know chemistry
test it's just you know you can't do DNA
testing on a human skin book because DNA
is too sensitive so if I was handling
the book which I do without gloves by
the way because that's like a myth in
rare books that you don't you know weird
our fingers yeah you know it's actually
less you're more likely to damage a book
or rip a page or something if you're
wearing gloves then if you have your
hair washed hands so if I was holding
one of those books and then you happen
to like take a sample off of this thing
you might get human traces where there
you know the leather itself was not
inhuman but also every time you do weird
process which like making skin into
leather is a pretty you know intense
process and also age the DNA just
degrades integrates integrates so DNA is
actually too sensitive and it doesn't
really work but the peptide mass
fingerprinting what you're looking at is
the collagen that's together and that
lasts for thousands of years and is very
very stable but you can only get down
sensitivity wise to the animal family so
he tested there were three alleged skin
but human skin books at Harvard and two
of them were fake but one of them was
real and then
kind of people freaked out our library
has human skin books yeah and then um so
I was kind of toying with doing another
book that was sort of related to death
and also things in collections and in
library collections and it says go to
Boston anyway I went and talked to
Daniel Kirby the chemist about it and
then I was like every time I go to a
library I was asking around about these
books and you know oh do you have one
like this do you have one and a
surprising amount of people are like
yeah actually we do have this book that
they say might be you know and so we
decided to compare notes and then we
also got another chemist on board and
then the curator or the museum we felt
formed this kind of interdisciplinary
group called the anthropogenic book
project so we've been trying to hunt
down these books in public collections
like libraries and museums around the
world and thus far we found about 50
like credible actually existent alleged
books and we've tested somewhere like 30
of them and about I want to say like 18
or so were real and 12 or fake you know
so it's a not quite even but pretty
close to even split and each time we
test one it is a whole new revelation we
learned because it's such a small cohort
you learned so much more about the
history each time you know there is one
book when we test it and it was this
people are like oh there must be like
sexy skin you know you know these like
erotic books and I was like no there
aren't any and then we tested one that
was it I was like okay well there is at
least one that's we there were three in
France at the bibliothèque nationale
that are actually incredibly old like
13th century Bibles that were allegedly
human skin but i I've seen them I've
been there but I very much doubt that
they're real they're completely out of
the
normal range of time and I don't think
the bond F is gonna give us slivers of
their 13th century Bibles I love it
anyone listening out that they have
books found in human skin yeah stuff
what is that whatever that that lame one
about the game back there but yeah so
I've seen them and they're beautiful
books on their own right but I just I
don't my spidey senses say probably not
but I try not to say yes definitely or
no yes I got the test yeah yeah we get
new results all the time there's not any
non-invasive tests that we have yet
right but this is so minimally invasive
it's like if you can see the sample with
your eye then that is plenty big right
so you can easily take a piece off of a
binding and you'll never notice that
it's gone the old DNA tests when they
tried to do stuff like that they would
take these huge stamp size squares have
something I threw in a book you can't do
that so this is more like you know you
can definitely test it and and find out
and it's this the beauty of it is that
it's a cheap and simple test and then
you have this whole world of knowledge
suddenly about this about this practice
so it just really I find it really
exciting every time we get results and
I'm just like so excited about learning
you know about these books and it's so
interesting to see people's reactions
and then because people have really wide
right reactions - some people are like
oh cool you know it's a some people are
like oh God you know or oh I'm so glad
this is fake so that we can stop telling
the campus tour guy is when the campus
tour guys come to zero no we don't you
know here's a handout about how this is
fake leave us alone
learn something else to say about the
library does your we're looking forward
to this to see your book have a title
it's called dark archives but the after
colon is not totally finished yet it's
something like books found in human skin
patient objectification and the
humanizing of medicine or something like
that is a long work
so but it will be out in the fall of
2019 excellent very very good so just
wrapping up any words of advice how
people should change their perspective
on death is there anything that you
learned that he sort of didn't have
already when you got into this how
should we just change our point of view
should we think about death more often
should we think about it as more fun
should we think it's more social what
should we do I I would say you know the
more that you interact with it the
easier it gets and that you can you know
it's you're never gonna not the goal
isn't to completely alleviate your fear
of death or whatever that's death is
still bad yeah it's scary oh it's gonna
be scary you know it's a scary thing
because you don't know when you don't
know how you know that's the ultimate
scary thing right but the more you talk
about it the more you can feel
comfortable about your choices the more
if you know if you know what a family
member once and you do the things that
they asked you to do that's one less
thing you ever have to think about like
did we do right by you know somebody so
the opening conversations and having
continual conversations over time
because your thoughts might change over
time your life situation changes over
time just keep like checking in on that
it really does alleviate some of the
anxiety of it and what I found
personally is and this wasn't something
I expected but looking back it does
actually make sense is that when you
realize that your life is actually
finite you appreciate your life more and
that was not an intention that I had
getting into this I was just interested
you know intellectually mostly and then
but it's kind of like I like to kind of
liking it too you know we grew up in
Pennsylvania right when you brushed your
teeth did you ever turn off the water
when you brushed your teeth no right why
would you do that ladies Coast thing
yeah why would you do that yes water you
well header will always come out you
have water all over the place it's just
there living in Los Angeles you realize
oh wait
water is finite yeah and it's really
important and you know it's not
necessarily going to be around forever
maybe I should be careful about the way
I use it maybe I can do simple things
like turning off the tap when I brush my
teeth and you know now I always turn off
the tap and that's sort of I appreciate
water when it rains here I'm like in
heaven
I'm so happy every time it rains if it
rained in Philly I wouldn't I would be
like oh great it's so annoying but here
it's like magical you know because I
appreciate it because it's not always
there and if you look at life that way
then you really live differently so when
big important things happen in my life I
actually tried to stop and take a moment
to like acknowledge that it happened
when we were talking about the rituals
and stuff those are stopping and taking
them up you know those are the things
that when you look back over your life
those are the things things that stick
out is like the moment that you took
when that happened like oh I remember
getting that phone call when I got into
you know that kind of those big things
like you take a moment to like remember
it and and then it's just I don't know
you just adds a lot to your appreciation
so your life has been enriched by taking
your death more seriously yes absolutely
all right Megan rosenbloom thanks so
much for being on the podcast thank you
[Music]